Since the nuclear deal was signed back in 2015,
the US Navy has seen a significant increase in the harassment
from swarms of Iranian small boats in the Persian Gulf.
These encounters put lives and shipping at risk.
In one instance, in April 2017,
the USS Mahan fired warning shots
and had to make dangerous changes of course to avoid hitting one of these vessels.
Why does Iran do this?
While this behavior may appear to be strictly aggressive,
Tehran actually has a very weak conventional navy,
and it's dependent on its asymmetric,
frankly guerilla-style, naval forces to deter more powerful adversaries like the US.
Regardless, Washington needs to respond more firmly,
and continue investing in new technologies like the Longbow Hellfire missile,
which can shoot out several missiles in sequence,
to ensure the safety of our personnel and freedom of navigation in the Persian Gulf.
To learn more about my takes on Iranian strategy and military power,
check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you want AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.